Greggy Johnny we are going to watch two
videos some solo a Star Wars story
combined into one here today we're going
to talk about both of them maybe it'll
give us something to talk about who
knows the most anticipated film of the
year yeah easily we wanted to say thank
you to everyone who's been joining our
patreon page becoming a patronage act
for the month of April we have been
growing over there so thank you guys so
much it's a lot of sobriety I do a few
more things over there we do full a TV
show reactions this guy and I have never
watched more animating our entire lives
plus superhero shows weekly q and A's
wanted to give a patron of the day shout
out to Austin Moore who has a YouTube
channel to serve fans zero seven one
seven productions haven't talked to this
guy in a little while but he has you
know these Lego Star Wars fan films that
he puts together him selves that are
very very good slinging brick last time
we talked I actually recorded some audio
because I am going to be part of his
next lego fan film and I am excited for
that I have never done more method
acting in my entire life why not apply
it to a voiceover right and also he's
working on a live-action fan film right
now so this guy's really busy dude he's
a really busy guy I've talked with him a
few times super passionate fans super
humble kind dude I can't wait to meet
you in person one day Austin and thank
you for being part of our patreon I hope
you're a real-life lego man no yeah yeah
yeah I hope it's he's an animatronic
yeah
anyway let's kick this thing off shall
we woo first right first one is a TV
spot called let's see here it's called
hon that's a good thing for a TV spot
for this movie to be one of the least
viewed TV spots wonder why okay
do something
second national anthem Star Wars
if you tell me comes
in his life for good
why not
solo the store war story so she just
like deliver his lines the same in every
single scene yes probably just this like
super calm even when they're doing the
Kessel run and remember that scene it's
yeah I can't tell if they're just
picking like two or three word moments
of his or not cuz I've seen this guy in
at least one movie and he was really
charming in that movie so like because
of that I'm rooting for him and I
thought that this TV spot might be an
opportunity they call it that on yeah
address the fact that it's pretty easy
to tell especially for Disney you're
looking around at reactions people we're
not thrilled about this and they're not
excited about at least I was like I hope
you're gonna take a chance Ison wise
this TV spot called hon when it does is
just a regular solos like a couple shots
of him with a cup like that's the
problem is like they show a couple shots
that weren't as familiar to me at least
where he looks a little more animated
I'm like can we stay on these for a
second let's just move on super quick
because that really gave us nothing to
work off like cool footage or whatever
but come on - come on this one though is
called becoming solo it's a feature
Rhett it's a two minute and 21 second
one I think Ron Howard's featured in
this he directed this feature which just
confuses me whenever I see Ron Howard
like talking about it you know as if
he's the only director yes credit is
this confusing what are you talking
about
it's Ron Howard's movie yeah purely he
did all the camp he wrote directed the
Star Wars universe that we see in so
long
it was different from anything else that
we've seen in a previous Star Wars movie
now sire controls everything everyone is
struggling to survive but we discover
this incredibly free spirit
we're meeting Tom right before it
becomes the harm that we know okay this
is more of a Han trailer than the last
is getting to see how this guy got to be
the way she is
it's all part of this great expansion of
the Han Solo a world it's a rite of
passage oh look at the tests he needs to
face the challenges he has to endure
whoa Wow
[Music]
today I first encounter did you win your
ship plane card I like this kid there in
this movie I'm a driver a great pilot
that seemed a little poor reminiscent
there terrible person does these stupid
things never work
[Music]
any person who knows what you really
[Music]
that is better than any trailer or TV
spot we've ever seen excited I've been
to see Han Solo so that was the only
time I've ever felt like oh I'm actually
yeah what you just said is the only time
I felt actually intrigued and excited
and genuinely curious to see this dudes
take on solo yeah there because this
whole featurette focused on the origin
of him you know I was like we all know
that we all like that's exactly what
this movie's market that's called solo a
Star Wars story but the marketing has
seemed a little bit confusing and not
really highlighting specifics as to who
Han is prior to this and I actually
started getting an actual sense of the
dude before he becomes the Han Solo we
all know yeah especially with Ron Howard
label him as this like sort of a
free-spirited kind of guy who could
probably arc into more of that cynical
type of Han Solo that we all come to
love when he's introduced in the first
Star Wars film and there were actual
moments where we got to see some whose
personality actually show us a glimpse
of his performance in your movie named
after his character
yeah a lot of the TV spots and a lot of
the things we've seen are just remixes
of all the images we've seen before and
this actually gave us some new scenes
some new creatures to look at some new
tone like that one battle scene made it
look kind of gritty and intense similar
to the way they went into a more war
movie aesthetic with row row one yeah
I've been interested and excited to see
Donald Glover as Lando this was the
first time and it's it never hit me
until now or I'm actually excited to see
Han Solo and Lando interested I really
hope this is not just a good feature
right and there's anticipation ow I'm
not saying I'm completely sold I'm not
saying I think it's gonna be a great
take but I'm curious yeah genuinely
interested because there was actual
moments here that were charming
and some stuff that seemed like he was
doing his own thing but slight forward
reminiscing yeah yeah exactly and I mean
I gotta say I've gotten to the point
where I'm kind of over hating this movie
preemptively and and I just kind of
waiting for it to entice me and that's
what this has helped to do so this is
actually building goodwill for me in the
Han Solo movie yeah yeah look how this
is more effective in the Han spot what's
going I want your marketing guys like
unless they just didn't know they were
like we're still expecting to finish
this movie we don't have that many clips
or something like fascinating
fascinating experience here alright guys
well thanks for watching Austin more
check out his channel disturb fans 0 7 1
7 productions one day I'll just remember
that F table man you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell to get notified when
we're business up let us know when you
get Star Wars tickets for solo and set
up patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly q and A's yeah just go there
today